bite the grand myth that black economic
progress began or celebrated with the
passage of the civil rights laws and the
war on poverty programs of the 1960s the
fact is that the poverty rate among
blacks
fell from 87 percent in 1940 to percent
in 1960
but over the next 20 years the poverty
rate among blacks fell another 18
percentage points this was just the
continuation of a previous economic
trend
but at a slower rate of progress it was
not
some grand deliverance close quote
that is so counter
to what we are taught in school what
appears on the editorial pages of
newspapers
that i have i feel as though i want to
ask you you really want to stick with
that
that is sort of i i i have more than my
most most recent book that
discrimination and disparities
i point out that this really is a
pattern not continuing to blacks or even
to the united states that you can see
the same thing in england you can see it
in any number of other countries that
the poor were or were much worse off
economically let's say in the first half
of the 20th century
and yet the
in terms of their own behavior
they were they were they had they were
far more decent
societies
and afterwards after after this welfare
state that's supposed to make them
better off and and better human beings
that's when the crime rate skyrocketed
on both sides of the atlantic
uh the british were not famous for being
perhaps the most polite considerate
society in the world
prior to that
uh after that you get things like the
2011 riots over there between london
manchester where they were they're going
through they they they anticipated
ferguson
uh and
and baltimore
by a few years
and the same thing is the the burning
down of buildings the throwing of
gasoline bombs
the whole schmear
uh and none of those people were
descendants of slaves
so so that
i'm trying to understand so he was
saying that
as the
poverty level
decreased
the crime level increased
um i think he's saying that when they
introduced the welfare state
okay and before the 60s like
people were poorer but there was less
crime and they were more polite and they
they acted more like decent in society
okay but then after the 60s or 70s when
the welfare state was introduced so that
was when um
they were he's probably going to get
into this in a second but like they were
incentivized to take the dad out of the
home because they would give money so
again that was a that was an the
intention was let's help the single moms
that are struggling so then but then
what's the government doing they're
incentivizing people to be single moms
they're paying you
per kid okay i
i do understand sorry guys i'm a little
slow
they use big words i'd be like
i like understand it but then i need
like another like explanation but i
i do understand that because
where i read it at there was a certain
point where they did
take the fathers out the home and
i don't i don't understand why
and i don't know if it was because like
oh you getting a sentence from
government if the father's not there i
can get paid
cool but
in the grand scheme of things it's not
helping
and it's just
a tactic that started and has continued
for years now and it
from the inside out has
just
i would say
taken a toll on the black community and
i wish i wish things like this
information like this was taught in
school
so people would know like what what
actually happened what
what was going on and why these certain
things happen instead of just like the
overarching theme like oh there was this
there was that and this is why this
happened yay great
but i think like if that was taught
then people would have people be able to
think differently and have a different
view and those laws wouldn't be able to
control people you have to think about
like when you when i look at a policy
you have to like i always say this you
have to think about it in the extreme
what is it incentivizing people to do
so if you give money to homeless people
from the government more people are
going to take advantage of it and it's
the same thing it doesn't mean all
people will because there's good people
and bad people but when you give people
the opportunity in a society to do the
wrong thing more people do it especially
when there's money involved
and i've heard of people having a kid so
they can get more money from the
government yep it's a thing like that
imagine being that kid
i couldn't i don't care how much money
i'm getting from the government i'm not
i'm not about to take care of a kid have
a kid no we're childless guys period
childlessness
but
it's
it's
irritating to
that that's a thing that
you you do something because you know
you're going to get money from it but
you don't think about
the consequences or the how it affects
the other people that come in especially
in the kids situation when you
say oh i know i'm gonna get this type of
money i don't wanna get um
i forgot what the word is but they get
moms get benefits to where they are able
to buy things it's like yes that's great
you're helping the single mom but if
your i your thought process was to
have a kid so i can get money so i can
be ballin it's like you're putting that
child in jeopardy and you're teaching
that kid like oh you don't need to do
anything for your own you can just
depend on the government to be able to
take care of you and you'll be fine you
can do exactly what i did i don't
i don't
no i don't like that i think not i think
but you should you should do things on
your own and if it
if you
you should just do things on your own
and not be like i'm just going to live
my life just
for
nothing and just depend on the
government the whole time yes there's
people in certain situations to where
it's like they
can't do nothing but depend
on i don't say nothing but they
have to depend on the government until
their situation change but i don't think
that should be your initial thought like
i'm going to do this so i can depend on
the government my whole life yeah but
that's why the government has to make
sure people aren't taking advantage of
it and that's why a lot of times it
sounds harsh especially like
you know the when the wealthy like like
the upper class will say oh no we don't
want government handouts but it's not
because of a lack of empathy like my
parents are very against government
handouts but they've taken in three kids
that were in bad situations that they
didn't they weren't looking to adopt
they just found the kids in bad
situations
but
had i put this like the issue is is from
a policy perspective you can't give
people too much free [ __ ] because
there's unintended consequences that you
don't you don't initially think about
and then it's the same thing
those politicians will say i fight for
single mothers i fight for the lower
class but they're they're killing these
community they're like tearing apart
community because there's more and more
single mothers because they know that
they can get benefits so you have more
and more young women
not thinking about the consequence of if
i have if i have sex with this man
there's a possibility i may get pregnant
but so it makes it essentially easier
like oh it's okay i know that i'm gonna
get money from the government but they
don't think about
the child's life
their life and how it affects it as a
whole but in the end i get money from
the government so that's all that
matters and then the other person like
do you know single women older women are
the
biggest like increasing sector of
homeless people really yeah because they
and it's um sad i hear a lot of girls
talk about how
they they're like afraid to settle down
with a guy because they know they have
to take care of their mom someday
because of the choices she made
and they don't want to they can't see
their mom get homeless
whoa
that's a d yeah because at some point
like the the free ship from the you need
2.5 million to retire
people need to be married like you you
can't do it on one income and so you
have all these single moms that
they're not prepared and then it takes
one cancer diagnosis to put them on the
streets yeah wow
oh and this is all from an unintended
this is all a consequence from someone's
who said let's help single moms
and it's it effectively destroyed a lot
of different communities
you can't one so you can't unsee it oh
my you cannot see it oh my goodness oh
oh
poor people were doing if the the lesson
of the 20th century is something like
poor people including in this country
african americans
were improving their lot and leading
fundamentally decent lives until the
government decided to help them yeah yes
that's a that's a fair statement
they're better off
economically because of what's been
given right but of course when you when
you have the crime rate
i mean i i got i got the first inkling
of this some years back when i was uh
at some school in harlem doing some
research
and i looked out the window and i
mentioned in passing that when i was a
little kid i used to walk my dog in that
park
and looks of horror came over the
students faces
nobody in his right mind would have a
child going to that park
walking a dog or not
the principal was warning these students
not to cross this park which is about a
block a half wide
even in groups of six
uh when i and and when i tell them about
how in this hot summer nights i would
sleep out on the fire escapes in harlem
they looked at me like i was a man from
mars people were doing that all over new
york they were doing it in philadelphia
washington wherever i've known people
that was a common thing for portland we
didn't have the money for air
conditioning right you slept out on the
fire escape or in the parks
where walton grew up in a walter
williams walter williams grew up in a uh
a housing project in philadelphia he was
saying on the hot summer nights the
people would be in this project have
little balconies they'd sleep out on the
balconies and the ones on the first
floor who didn't have balconies would
sleep out in the yard
and that there were old men who would
you could see sit on a hot summer night
sitting outdoors into the wee hours
playing cards or
or checkers or whatever
it was a different world
[Music]
infinitely safer now what about family
structure
you would think that
having
being more like
economically like wealthy and getting
help from the government it would
essentially
make people's
their you would be see a better way of
life
but to hear him say that when
they weren't getting handouts from
the government when they weren't getting
government benefits it was
essentially better and safer and it
changed when this is like
i'm trying to wrap my head around and
understand like
why why is that because money doesn't
fix problems that's that
but like
how many nba players go broke
a lot those are those are guys that get
to live a better life than like anyone
in history they get
they get to be young and wealthy which
is rare right most people if they are
wealthy they're old so they get to
experience their youth
as many women as they could possibly
want
and and half of them go broke because
they they're it's like quick money and
and i just think
like
it doesn't it doesn't solve your
problems like they always say money
doesn't
change who you are it shows who you are
so
yeah wow
what
okay so with that
that quote
oh
my brain is like everywhere right now
because
it's
it's hard to
to know that
before the government stepped in and was
like hey we're going to
essentially help out this community
where where would
where would we be now where would black
people be now if that never had happened
would
we be
less than where we are now or better
they were economically outpacing white
people before like they were growing
like yeah
and one of the one of the minimum wage
laws actually the the biggest
in california one of the first minimum
wage laws actually disproportionately
affected young black teens
because what did it do like they a lot
of people say it was racist
because instead of hiring the teenagers
and that was like one of the most like
that was
the people that were the most affected
because that's that's what happens you
you work your way up to a higher income
yeah
wow
and so yeah and it's crazy because
it's really hard to explain this to
people because they really make you out
to be you see how they paint
conservatives in the media
like it's not
they they make you out to be like oh
you're not helping poor people when like
honestly
conservatives are like the most giving
people they just do it privately
it's not like they're not leaving your
face well because people are more
charitable but more money they make
they just not not to the government so
like when people like like even with the
um with the environment like the one of
the number one indicators that a
community is going to care about the
environment is that they make money like
that the economic prosperity that's why
you see like rich neighborhoods it's
nice
because when people have money when
you're poor like you don't have time to
care about other people
you're trying to figure out yourself
yeah yeah but that's that's where you
get these like huge donations a lot of
the time
interesting because i know
if i was up in that tax bracket i'd be
like oh yeah i would be more willing to
give out money here and there to help
people but but you also i'm going to
tell you the other side of this people
like because when you're when you're
wealthy when you're wealthy
people really take advantage of it like
and this is coming from up from like
i've seen my parents get backstabbed by
people that we have let them live with
us
we have let them because they'll just
think oh they're rich it doesn't matter
and like like we had a nanny we were
employing her we
we we were paying like she was going on
trips with us she had all this [ __ ]
it's the hand that feeds you because she
she stole like they she bought a laptop
off of like on their credit card oh wow
and it wasn't a lot of money to them
right but it's not about the money it's
like they're principally yeah it's like
it's the respect thing and
that's
that's the problem it's like a
double-edged sword
like because you want to be and and we
are like you know i mean they took in
three kids that weren't theirs but it's
just like
it's i i think it's part of human nature
to be honest to see how much you can get
away with
yes yes it is
man i'm still stuck on that quote you
said earlier
most black children were being raised in
two parent families in 1960.
30 years after the liberal welfare state
the great majority of black children
were being raised by single parents yeah
how what what what's the what how does
that by the way we should note
that
and okay because before there was a
consequence
and this is in society if you take away
the consequences to every anything more
people do it before if you were a single
mom you damn near were maybe homeless
okay so so people were a lot more scared
to get pregnant
you know it's crazy there were less
single moms then and it was easier to
get pregnant there was birth control no
birth control yeah so it's like easier
for us to avoid pregnancy yeah and there
was less of them men
how what do you think that there was
less because
a lot of the men were off at war i mean
was there
my history is horrible i don't know
do you think that it was less because
the men were
essentially doing more or weren't at
home as
much
do you think that's
why do you think
no i think i think again it's you they
took away the consequence of being a
single mom
if you were a single mom before you were
[ __ ] out of luck
and now and now the government yeah they
give you money
so
so before it was you you'd be afraid of
being homeless now there's no fear
because they take away the consequence
oh this video's gonna make my head
explode
and the thing with money showing who you
are like if if you got rich tomorrow
like i i think you'd probably
live a little like you'd probably spend
a little bit more
but are you
i'm
if i got rich tomorrow i would act like
i have no money still no
i'd probably be able to like go out to
eat a little bit more splurge a little
bit treat myself but i would
essentially for me i think i would act i
would act
the same and it wouldn't be like oh i'm
learning to design and stuff like no i
have clothes i'm still going to keep
them but like the things that i want
that i know like if i got them now i
would hurt in another area i would be
able to be like okay i can get that i
can get that i can get that and get that
and essentially
make things
better for
any situation that i wanted to and i
would be able to help out my my family
but i wouldn't
yeah because that's who you are and it's
the same thing with me like i'm not
going to buy designer clothes
but i i would buy a second soundboard
send money
if you're in premiere if you're in
premiere send money please please go to
the uh pregame show super chats please
pat moynih patrick moynihan publishes
the moynihan report in 1965
and he's alarmed because the
illegitimacy rate among black
families is 25 then
now among whites it's over a third
hispanics it's over half and among
african americans it's over 70 percent
what's going on there
well this is how again this too you find
the same thing in britain you find it in
uh
france and norway you find it in the
western world
uh and in fact uh the dissolution of the
family structure oh yeah there are any
number of western nations where forty
percent of the children are uh are
raised with with only one parent right
uh at the extremes
uh ice
compared to
asian countries
at the extremes of iceland it's uh two
out of three
uh children born are raised in a single
parent home uh in south korea it's one
out of 66.
wow
wow
and so what that's the welfare state
what yes it is are you you're paying you
you're creating a situation where the if
the uh first of all the
well you're cr you're creating a
situation where if the man stays there
the the government will not give them
give the woman welfare
uh and if he leaves he
it will and so they're pa they're paying
when you pay people not to get married
more people don't get married right
it's so simple
but yet it's so like
because you're not really taught this
you're not at all you just think oh the
the idea that i had about welfare is
that
if you if you're struggling or if you
can't afford something that's when you
get on welfare and that's it and a funny
thing
there's a movie called kingdom come and
there's a um
scene where um
loretta divine she's the actress
and her son i cannot remember his name
but it was the um
the oldest son in
family matters have you seen family
matters
and so
she
she's a church-grown woman and so she
was he was telling her like yeah i'm
gonna find me a church-going girl settle
down have a couple kids and then we're
gonna get a welfare and so that's just
that's something that keeps popping into
my head whenever they say welfare and to
un to know
like
what it
it is it's like
welfare
this
it's
literally the one of the worst things
that could have been implemented into
the government
she's going to become a conservative
this is
for and i understand why they don't
teach it in school because if they
taught it in school then it wouldn't be
a thing anymore more and more people
would not
more people wouldn't be single mom more
more people wouldn't do the things that
causes them to depend on
they're paying you to make poor
decisions
and the people and the people that make
good decisions pay for it like my dad my
dad okay my dad was
was like poor like he grew up one of 13
kids wow he
south side of chicago well half his
childhood he spent in like rural
wisconsin and half in the south i don't
know they'd move every four years i
don't know why wow my grandpa was a fire
my grandpa was a fireman's that's not my
grandma didn't work that wasn't a crazy
good salary right for 13 kids they
should yeah yeah we had 13 kids yeah
firefighter yeah okay so it wasn't like
he grew up rich my dad is a workaholic
he my dad has made every good just like
better decisions that i've even made
like never drank never done drugs
never
i think he said he smoked a cigarette
once in third grade and he didn't like
it that was it
he he he married the girl he started
dating in his early 20s
had
seven kids by her grew a milk
multi-million dollar but like did this
why does he have to pay
for someone else's poor decisions he
just chooses because there are people
that just choose not to work and i'm not
against no safety net like i think
there's you know mentally disabled
people yeah people with a very low iq
that just can't function in society you
have to think of them but like
like that's that's
because i think naturally i lean more
left because i'm a very empathetic
person and i really i enjoy helping
people so my personality is more left
but when my dad explains this to me i'm
like yeah why should you have to pay for
that
yeah as you understand you understand
both
both sides
of it and
it's
my like literally my mind is
everywhere right now with this
information and
i
i didn't want to be thinking about this
all day
and i'm going to sit down and be like
what bro
where
where could
society be
and just like thinking about like the
black community like what
like well i i think there is someone i
have a theory that there is someone
racist like behind the scenes that i
knew yeah
no no no no like
no no like like i don't know who it was
but because they implement this and it
disproportionately affects the black
community and then on top of that
abortion yeah like that the black
population would be double today if it
weren't for abortion like that is a
disproportionately like that affects
that community and so like how crazy is
that there would be double of everybody
and so on top of that yeah like and and
the person who started planned
parenthood she believed in like keeping
the bloodline pure like she was a
eugenic like i don't i forget the word
for it but like where where you believe
in like keeping like i don't know pure
blood like whatever like if i didn't
know what he said no i don't know
i think it's eugenic like she just
basically believed in basically breeding
and she was like and so they literally
marketed planned parenthood to black
communities
and and they basically succeeded because
the black community would be doubled
today and like you never hear about this
like i
imagine if nike was founded this way
imagine
imagine if nike had some
but but for whatever reason planned
parenthood gets a pass why
why
oh and it's the same people they say
they're for women's rights
okay so how does how does an abortion
help me
does that make me in a better mental
state but there's a lot of there's a lot
of like
physical stuff that happens when you
get an abortion and it could and mental
and it encourages you to make what bad
decisions
it encourages women to sleep around like
they're saying oh it's okay sleep around
as much as you want there's no
consequences for it which is a lie
that's a lie because we release a
hormone men don't when we have sex so we
get attached and they don't
so do that as much as you want even and
get pregnant and there's still no
consequence because you can
get an abortion it's just like
they take away personal responsibility
yo
oh
oh my
jesus
right okay so so what would have
happened
if lyndon johnson instead of becoming a
liberal
had remained a crusty tough skeptical
texas texas conservative yes which is
certainly the way he started his career
if he if lyndon johnson had embraced the
constrained
vision
instead of instituting the war on
poverty and the great society and so
forth what would the country look like
today a lot better you would not have
the same rates of crime and so on
because you see you can't have a welfare
state in a democratic country unless you
first have a welfare state vision and
when you buy all the assumptions of that
vision then you're buying a lot of
trouble one of the one of the episodes i
think epitomized it was in france in
this case
uh that there were attacks knife attacks
by various people from north africa
against chinese people in uh in some
suburbs of paris
and one of the
things that
the attacker said you know that
why are you attacking the chinese and it
wasn't because anything the chinese had
done to them he said they have nice
clothes and big cars that's not fair
i mean that's you know
egalitarianism as a philosophy is one
thing but the actual consequences of it
are mean things like resenting other
people's good fortune right
so i wonder
what was it
that this person that implemented this
law what was it about the
black community that they did not like
that they were like hmm if we do this
this is going to
change the whole trajectory of the whole
community
and negatively affect them but
positively benefit us
i don't know
i don't i couldn't tell you
oh
but you see what he said there with the
hating you hear this narrative well
they'll be like eat the wretch
like let's tax the red like you know
what i'm saying there's more money it's
like a jealousy thing
yeah and and here's the thing here's the
thing if
let's say what if what if amazon jeff
bezos said you know what screw all you
people
i'm done amazon poof gone
and instead of like it would it would be
terrible and we're not even thankful to
these people it's like we hate them why
they're providing a service we all enjoy
literally everybody bro i could not live
without amazon everybody would went
crazy during the pandemic if they didn't
have amazon
but we hate them even though we benefit
and you'll see it the more you're gonna
because you're gonna see it the more
successful you get people that aren't no
no people that aren't successful are
going to be jealous of you and feel like
they're entitled to
wow
yeah like it it happens all the like all
the time because my parents i swear to
god the nicest kindest most giving
people i know i like i love my parents
but you also grow up seeing people
really take advantage of that and become
entitled wow like we had people we were
funding we were funding their life
my dad would give them like a salary per
year not they didn't even work like a
relative right they
they i'm not going to say what they did
but they did something like very
backstabby to my dad
they were family yeah it was the hand
that hand that fed him yeah
because we remember 1 to 13. there's a
lot of them yeah
but yeah it's just like like resentment
in comparison it's the thief of joy
and if if this stuff was
i'm just like thinking about if this
stuff was actually like
taught to people at a young age they
would be able to
think differently and
know that okay
this was implemented for
a negative effect i'm not going to go
down the same route that
they want me to i'm going to strive to
do better but we're not taught that
as
i'll tell you why oh they're okay
because you can't see this because the
schools are in like cahoots with the
government they're the governor yeah so
the problem is that they're not going to
teach it to you in schools because
that would require holding schools
accountable
and it's like like it used to be that
people could pick where to send their
kids to school and this this
disproportionately affected the black
community too because if you were low
income you could still send your kid to
a good school you wouldn't you weren't
stuck by that zip code but now where
you're born you're forced to go to a
[ __ ] school no matter how bad the
teachers are and if you
did you hear the story about the mom
that
sent her child and she
i don't i can't remember she went to
jail but she initially got in trouble
for it yeah and it's like
how do you want better
for your child
but essentially get in trouble for it
but it's like you're not putting anybody
in harm's way you're not doing you're
just sending them to a better school to
have a better life oh my god and this is
what this is what blows my mind so in
chicago okay
they get 13 000. last i checked around
12 13 000 per kid so every kid that goes
to a school the government gives you the
12 13k to the to the city of chicago
okay chicago has terrible schools you
know those better test scores my school
you know what the tuition is in my
school eight thousand dollars per kid
you know the difference between us and
the public schools the public schools
had really nice facilities they had a
beautiful gym all this [ __ ] okay
my school didn't have any of that we
didn't have air conditioning but they
invested in what teachers
oh wow oh because like a nice gym is
gonna make you more educated
so so it's like the the and
but the problem with teaching positions
is it's like it's there there's no
incentive there's no
if you teach for 10 years you're on
tenure they can't fire you yeah and then
okay and then you're going to see this
differently too because the unions like
teachers unions are basically to protect
teachers from getting fired but some of
them should get fired yeah and so
they'll march the streets and say oh
we're fighting for teachers you're not
fighting for teachers if you're a good
teacher you're not going to be let go
yeah exactly so but it's really hard to
fire teachers especially if they've been
there after a certain time and no matter
how no matter how
bad they are
if they hit a certain mark like tenure
they get to stay and they get to
continually
teach
the way they are teaching
and i've had teachers that have been
like why why are you a teacher
why are you here you hate your life when
you're here you don't want to you don't
want to
teach us anything that's actually going
to help us why are you here
and and you know what you know what
would help but they used to do charter
schools so you could say okay the 13k
that the government gives the schools
for my kid i wanted to go to that school
and then do you know who would do you
know who would you would see if they did
that you would see business people jump
in
because they're like oh [ __ ] i can make
thirteen thousand dollars a kid
i'm gonna figure out a way to educate
them in the best way possible so i can
make money like wanting to make money
isn't a bad thing if you're providing a
service that everybody needs but the
problem is the government strong arms
these parents descending like it's not
fair and i say this like if there's one
policy i could like fight for it would
be
education equality because that's like
you shouldn't just because you're born
poor you shouldn't be stuck having a
[ __ ] education like i got a good
education because my parents could
afford it that's not fair
like
and so it's like the same thing they
take away the consequence for the school
because no matter how bad of a job they
do
the government still
pays them and the consequence used to be
i'm pulling my kid yeah but now they're
he'll send you to jail
and then the teachers will say oh
let's fight for more pay but it's not
it's about
you
there's a school in new york that did it
because so there are charter schools a
little bit right
but
there aren't enough so it's by it's by
lottery basically so it's like it's like
at random you can apply to possibly but
you have to be chosen
and there was a school in new york that
did it they paid all their teachers six
figures wow they and you had people that
like weren't even teachers applying that
were just like really good at music
really good because i think there's so
many people that like i would teach if
there was more money in it
i would and there was some incentive
like where it wasn't just
like if i if i was better at teaching i
would get more money yeah but
like i would do a youtube course i
totally like there's a ton of kids i
want to do oh yeah yeah sure and
like and i would be good at it too i'd
be really good at but i would never do
it because i don't want to make 45k a
year for like for what no and not and
live off of 10 like it's just not but
the
and at that school they literally
recorded lectures and then after school
they would tell them okay this you say
it this way that's wrong you need to
explain it in that way and like it was
like and like teachers would quit
because it was so stressful but these
kids improved so much like they was all
low-income kids that improv like had a
yeah
but why isn't
like stuff like that
why isn't that because the way they
market it they market it they say oh
you're not fighting for teachers like
they you like did you you remember when
the i don't know if you heard of this
but in chicago there's a really big
teachers like riot and like they're on
strike
which is so selfish
like it's not about you it's about the
kids yes exactly like
yes teachers
if you if you
believe if you're
i won't even say that but
essentially it's not
it's not about you if you're
it's about the kids in the grand scheme
of things and
if you're not
like like i said my brain is everywhere
around
i work for youtube i can't be on strike
if i about strike from youtube i just
stopped getting paid yeah exactly
and and like negotiate with your
employer like figure or or go get a
better like go negotiate with another
school but you're making the kids pay
for this yeah
i never understood a strike bro i'm like
i'm not about to go on strike and miss
money like
yes i may be
it may be low it may not be where i want
it to be but if i'm gonna go talk to
somebody take a take a day off and not
get paid just to walk around no
no and then go back to work and nothing
changed and i missed a day of work yeah
no i want to i'm telling you once you
see it you can't unsee it
all right so
one response to the gap
again i returned to this gap between
african-americans and other americans
affirmative action yes which brings us
back to your alma mater harvard
according to i know i'll never live it
down you'll never live it down yes
you once told me that the principal
benefit of a harvard degree was never
again having to be impressed by anybody
who had harvard degrees
absolutely
so
these are figures that were published in
the harvard crimson the student
newspaper in the harvard class of 2019
these are the kids who will be
graduating next june the average sat
score for black students was 21.49
by the way these are all good scores but
for black students 2149 white students
2218 asian students 2 300. well now that
must be reasonable because it's taking
place at harvard the seat
of reason
well well that wasn't quite how i
described it when i was there
affirmative action is that is that
we ought not to be doing this
you know there are various uh
laws and policies that benefit one group
at the expense of another
but i think affirmative action has the
distinction of being one that harms
everybody though in different ways
and so you there
there's a lot of evidence
that there are black kids who have all
the qualifications to be successes in
college who nevertheless are failures
because they are systematically
mismatched with institutions whose
standards they don't meet even though
they may meet the standards of 80 or 90
of the colleges in america
i remember first aware of this when i
was teaching at cornell
why isn't i wish that something that was
taught
in school like
these are
your qualifications yes you may want to
go to this ivy school but you'll be more
successful if you go to these schools
because it shouldn't be taught they
should be denied
that's true like you shouldn't be
accepted to a school you're not
qualified for
that's true but then it goes back to
what we talked about last time quota
uh-huh and
it hurts and and it hurts the smartest
kids too
because that's as he said someone that
goes to harvard even you know that you
have to have some like they might but
they're gonna think they're dumb
and they're not they're smarter than 80
to 90 percent of people yeah
it's there's just so much that
could
possibly positively affect
a nation but it's like
why why is it like why isn't it
happening
but i know that if it happens
then
people are going to
become more as independent or like be
able to think for themselves and not
have to
depend depend on the government or
depend on this depend on that and it's
going to be less and less of
like a
a hole that
these overarching things have on people
and people are going to be more free to
be a human
and
it's the media i'm telling you and and
the crazy thing it's the same thing
that's right i hate people that are act
like they're doing the right thing so
the people they're saying oh well i'm
fighting i'm fighting for black people
i'm letting them into harvard i'm we
need these quotas
but if it hurts it hurts yeah if it's
not like yes you could be letting them
in but
if it's not a successful situation for
them how are you how are you helping
them yes on their resume may say harvard
and they may
but if they don't graduate there's
nothing on the resume yeah and they
switched their major like he he might
talk about this in a second because i've
read a couple of his books
and and one of his books
he said like it would i can't remember
but it was a high percentage would
switch their majors from like
engineering to to an art
to or something easier to communicate
graduate yeah
yeah do you realize how many more people
would actually
if
if we
if they were
if they went to the schools that they
were more successful at do you realize
how many more people would use their
majors pick a major that they
enjoyed and that they were successful in
and afterwards be able to use it instead
of just picking an easy major just just
to graduate well and then oh my gosh
this is another layer okay another layer
is that the reason there's so much
college debt is because they took away
the consequence like usually
people should be denied for loans that
can't afford loans
but that's that's how it worked before
they subsidized education in the 1960s
or 70. i don't remember what year but
late 90s
but whenever whenever that happened what
they did was say you were going gonna
give there oh we want more poor people
to go to college right so so let's give
all of them loans anyone can get a loan
regardless and instead of being denied
those loans they were given loans and
now you see people paying off college
debt
into their 50s like that's that's insane
and then it hurts the people later so
that's another problem as to why you see
so many people going to colleges they
can't afford and getting degrees that
don't make any money and it hurts you
know who it hurts the most to
poor kids because like at least me even
even upper like middle class even even
the kids that like my parents could
afford my college but the kids i grew up
around they knew to get a degree in
engineering math like my my dad no you
can't get a like i i'm doing
communications right but i have an
economics degree because he was like i'm
not paying for a degree that doesn't
have an roi
oh wow
so and you know it helps me a little bit
on the channel still probably more than
a communications degree honestly but
like if you don't have that guidance and
you're 18 sure i'll sign up for college
not everyone is college that they don't
know any better
how are you supposed to know
mm-hmm now they're saying oh forgive all
college debt but now what about the
people that did the right thing and paid
it off
yeah do they do they get reimbursed for
that did you get their money back
no
that's crazy what i was just thinking
about like if
if we were taught that go to a school
that you can or if they didn't
ever implement the law like we're going
to give you
any type of loans
and
you went to the school you could afford
went to the school you were most
successful in
in
in the black community
would there be so many
kids that are in sports and they think
that that that's their way out and if
they don't play a sport they can't get
out would that would they resort to that
or would they resort to
i this is a college i can afford this is
a college i know i'm going to be
successful in
and i'm able to play a sport with
academics come before the athletics
you would think that you would think if
they were taught the numbers because
your chance of going to the league is
slim yeah
my parents always told me like even now
i have a chance i could play pro if i
want in um probably germany or something
my dad tells me it's not a career that's
not your future
you can do it if you want but it's not
your future because there's so there's
so many
that think i'm going to the league i'm
going to the inside
you may be great great for your high
school great for your college but
it's it's so hard and there's so like
it's such a slim little area to where
that you actually are able to go
to
play in
the league and then if you don't it's
like
devastating you went to college with
this
major that you didn't really care about
but you needed to major because you
needed to play basketball but now like
what what do you have to fall back on
oh
and and you know they don't push either
plumbers electricians i'm talking about
that with my mom traits like trade work
it's like
she when she was going to school she was
that was something that was implemented
in school like trade work being being a
plumber being in an electrician hardware
and um
welding like those are
well paid jobs but they're not
looked at as well painted out because oh
it's a plumber like a trash a trash man
he made babies
if i would have known that i would be
out there driving that truck
go to the back of the truck i'd be out
there i'd be a trash woman right now if
i would have known nothing like they
make money or anyone like that it's
trash wow
and
it's like
oh okay all right
and i found that half the black students
at cornell were on some kind of academic
probation
and so i went over to the administration
building look up the sats of these
students the average black student at
cornell at that time scored at the 75th
percentile
which is pretty darn good yes
and so that means that
in most colleges in this country they
would have no trouble and many of them
would be on the dean's list
but at cornell the average a liberal
arts student at that time was in the
99th percentile
and and when you when you when you're
teaching
students like that uh you teach at a
pace
that most people
of any race cannot keep up with
and i i was it was always complained
that i was assigning all kinds of uh
reading
but heck i'm teaching kids who are in
the top one percent they can they they
can keep up with it with the reading
that i'm assigning
uh so cornell was taking very talented
black kids and spending four years
teaching them to feel inadequate yes
six and succeeded
oh this is
this is not a good video to watch right
now while it's this time of the month
because it's emotional to oh
yeah just like
where could those like those kids that
he was talking about that were on
academic probation where could they have
been if they were placed in a situation
for them to succeed i'm thinking about
just
my friends my family that if they were
put
in a a situation to
now and that's why i succeed quotas are
racist it's white people saying oh black
people can't do it themselves that's
racist
oh that's like that's it's yes it's so
racist saying that you need our hope
yeah you need our help
like the audacity of these people the
audacity but we never look at it like
that it's the same thing like honestly
my am i having your reparation same
thing
you need art we need to say like
like you're not you're not competent
enough to do it yourself you can't you
can't get out of the situation
you're in
so you need you need our help you need
reparation that revelation will be nice
and like
extra money but like you need like you
need you need the government you need us
our help you need the quotas you need
the sat in the third to be able to get
out the situation it's like that is
it may not be taught to us like right in
our face but subconsciously that is
something that's implemented in the in
just society and it's taught us
subconsciously to where
we don't realize we're depending on this
that and the third to be able to get our
situations like we don't no you can't oh
no like
oh
okay we're just gonna keep going
um
a couple quotations this is these are
both from the last affirmative action
case to reach the supreme court last big
affirmative action case to reach the
supreme court 2003 uh grudder vs
bollinger
here's the majority opinion which was
written by justice sandra day o'connor
quote
the court expects that 25 years from now
the use of racial preferences will no
longer be necessary this upholding the
use of in a decision 5 4 decision
upholding the use of racial preferences
now that's quotation 1 here's quotation
2 justice thomas justice clarence thomas
in a descent quote
i believe that blacks can achieve in
every avenue of american life
without the meddling of university
administrators
the court holds that racial
discrimination and admission should be
given another 25 years
while i agree that in 25 years these
practices will be illegal
they are illegal now
[Laughter]
close quote
so
here's
what do you do with the argument that
justice o'connor writing that majority
opinion
there's something of the constrained
vision there look we have these all
universities across the country are
using these racial
preferences to as the basis of admission
the best we can hope to do is tell them
they ought not to be doing it that they
should be developing other standards and
give them a give them a clock
is that a reasonable thing to do
no but it's a universal thing to do
i wrote a book
about affirmative action
it was called affirmative action around
the world and i made a couple of uh
international trips at the expense of
the hoover institution
around the world to check on affirmative
action this is one of the one of the
most common arguments that is absolutely
fallacious time and time again the
argument that
like so much in the unconstrained vision
it assumes that we have a power that we
do not have
cannot have and never had to have had
in england there was a man named skarman
who was saying for the now we must do
this in order to order and in many
countries these these programs were set
up with an actual cut-off date
so it was set up with in malaysia with a
cut-off date i think of sprout
1990 and in pakistan it was like it was
supposed to go for 10 years
none of those
cut off dates has meant
a thing these programs not only continue
they increase they spread
so the idea that you can control for the
future
because of these wonderful sounding
words
i can't think of a country in the world
the way where that's ever happened
in the case of pakistan they did have an
absolute
actual cut-off date
uh and because people in east pakistan
were for whatever historical reason way
behind the people in west pakistan and
so there's these preferences for east
pakistanis
now before time for this thing to expire
the east pakistanis uh cc from pakistan
and formed a new nation of bangladesh
right and the preferences continued
right on because there were other groups
that had been added to it and so once
you get the constituency you can't say
no to them
i see it
it is an argument that that
has never worked out anywhere that i've
been able to to check all right so
tom sol says no to the welfare state no
to affirmative action
what is to be done and now you were kind
enough to share with me
uh the galleys of your forthcoming
edition of discrimination and
disparities let me give you a few
quotations from
some of the the new chapter in that book
quote
the poverty rate among black married
couples has been less than 10 percent
every year since 1994. as far back as
1969
young black males whose homes included
newspapers magazines and library cards
had similar incomes to those of their
white counterparts
academic outcomes show a pattern of
disparities similar to the pattern of
disparities in the amount of time
devoted to school work
apparently
lifestyle choices have
consequences yes close quote
so this is the constrained vision once
again
welfare state that's government we don't
rely on that
affirmative action government we don't
rely on that
we rely on hard work
we rely on the institution of marriage
is that's correct
yes in other words these things i don't
think it's the marriage especially the
library cards as such
it's that there are lifestyle choices
that have been made and the comparison i
made was between if you look at the
poverty rate among blacks uh uh it was a
22 percent and among whites was 11
but among black married couples it was
7.5 right so it's not so they not only
do better than blacks as a whole they do
better than whites as a whole and so
it's it's so it's lifestyle choices
similarly with with the results and the
some of these are more successful
charter schools
but then you implement the welfare
system and that destroys it
i think there's a stat that say that
says
i'm getting the number partially wrong
but i want to say
18
of men in the black community father 80
percent of the kids
and um
half of half of like 45 or 50
of black guys are single childless in
the middle class
and yet on the media we see
them painted as like entertainers as
players but literally
it's it's a very small percentage that
actually is oh
oh my
goodness
oh
she's red pilling on camera oh my
goodness my brain is doing
somersaults right now with
yeah
yeah we're just gonna keep doing some
research uh you have these kids not only
uh meeting but exceeding the national
standards in places like harlem and
beverage divers in the south bronx
and these are not kids who are
skimming the crown cream they're kid's
chosen by lottery
they don't even test them for ability
they don't even look at their academic
records they take them into the schools
and
they and they have hearts the charter
system i was telling you about yeah
that's what he's talking about so that's
what he said they don't test you it's by
lottery
okay remember when i was saying the
charter yeah okay at work and they make
it clear at the outset and they don't
tolerate a lot of nonsensical behavior
uh and and these kids are doing
incredibly so tom here
again i think back to the moynihan well
no i think so the moynihan report in 65
and he was very alarmed by
the illegitimacy rate of 25 among
african-americans by the way in fairness
to the late moynihan we should point out
one reason he was alarmed by this was
his own his own father had walked out on
the family when he was 10 years old he
experienced what it meant yes to be to
kids to have one parent okay and now
it's all gotten dramatically worse for
whites and hispanics and for everybody
and then i think
back beyond that to your experience of
harlem
you drop out of high school and do what
go on welfare
start cashing no you went to work
and you spent some of that money to buy
some inexpensive encyclopedias yeah
and the
harlem was
so
but i feel this uh council it's it's
almost a council of despair
in that that world just seems so utterly
vanished
but so your argument is if if we can
stand up to the welfare state
we can somehow get back to that world a
family family structure will reassert
itself
that's gonna that that's gonna be
reconquering the same ground which is
really tough to do
but it can't it can be done
i was i was so lucky
at the time i had no no clue about all
this
as i was thinking earlier i'm like how
how can a 16 year old high school
dropout
go to college go to a prestigious class
like harvard
get a bachelor's get a master's and a
doctorate
but nowadays if you do that oh your life
is over
like high school dropout that you have
to like have some sort
of something to be able just to move on
to the next level education and it's
like
it's mind-blowing as to
how not i won't say simple but how does
like
less complicated it was back in the day
to be able to
before
this implement implementation of welfare
came along and it's like
burn it down take it away i don't want
it anymore i mean i'm not benefiting
from it but
oh
like we actually have a question i left
home do most of the people you know that
are chronically in poverty is it because
of their choices or because of where
they were born
more
you have to pick one
more i know i know it's both i know both
definitely goes into it
i would say
more of their
choices because yes they were born into
a
difficult situation
or a harder situation than normal
but their choices
have
landed them where they are now because
if they would have made different
choices they would be in a different
situation it's interesting i know rich i
know kids from rich families that are in
poverty because they just spend money
they don't have wow like i know like i
have a
close
relative that will always be broke
because he
does not know how to save money he's
always spending money he doesn't have
like
and sure he lives off my pa like he he
gets some money from my parents for now
but at some point he's like after after
a certain age he's going to get caught
he'll he'll be broke forever
because he just doesn't
have any discipline or self-control
and you see it in his life because he's
very overweight he's very like it's
usually not just one thing i've noticed
like like some not everyone overeats
right like they might be but you just
notice it's not like the lack of
discipline is just everywhere
it's a snowball effect one thing and
then it just
builds it to another yeah
uh
at the uh in 1948
uh many decades later i learned that the
uh
unemployment rate among black teenagers
in 1948
16 17 year olds
was uh
9.4 percent
among whites of the same age it was 10.2
percent so both blacks and white
teenagers
had only a fraction of the unemployment
that they have today
uh you were expected to work you were
expected to be able to get a job and
more importantly the jobs were there for
you
uh and so and what this is because of a
fluke really the the the minimum wage
law in the united states fairly
understand this act of 1938
was passed with specified
rates of pay that you're supposed to get
uh almost immediately uh inflation took
off during the 1940s
so by 1948 those numbers that were in
the law were meaningless oh i see you
know in other words when i started out
as a western union messenger the minimum
wage was 40 cents an hour i started out
at the bottom at 65 cents an hour so it
was the same as if there was no minimum
wage and this is what happened you had
this
i was so lucky i knew of course i had no
clue about any of this
now now a black kid 20 years later comes
in there
uh they've now
they've people have become compassionate
they've raised the minimum wage so he
can't get a
job got it and i don't think it does any
community any good to have a whole lot
of teenage
males
hanging around on the streets with no
job and nothing to do
oh my
so many
and it's the same people you know it's
crazy these same people will say oh i'm
helping communities i'm doing this this
and this and i swear to god jess the
people that do the most say the least
the people that act like they do
everything yes bro they do nothing
even i'm so
oh
i'm thinking about something i'm trying
to like connected to see if it would be
a thing and what i'm thinking about
is
would it
would there have been
any i won't say any but would there have
been an inflammation of crack into the
black communities if this was something
that
wasn't a thing like would that have
would that have been
an avenue for people to
make money but
illegally and then if this was
implemented they wouldn't they wouldn't
have needed to make money legally
because they would have had the job
opportunities to work and then
there wouldn't be
it's kind of weird timing it's kind of
weird it's kind of weird timing how that
happened right around the same time the
welfare state was introduced kind of
weird timing
burned the whole country down cut
kind of weird and you know what's crazy
too i know people
um i know someone that
dealt drugs when they were younger and
you do you know who got him into it
his teacher
bro
it was like a school
yeah i was like a gym teacher or
something wow
so it's like literally from
the system that's supposed to protect
you yeah
you know what's crazy that same teacher
runs a dare program now oh bro i know
they're like yeah he changed the name
get him canceled i don't i don't know
the name
this guy just told me that i was like
what the [ __ ]
what
imagine if that person
didn't have a change of heart how many
other
students
i don't even believe he had a change of
heart no i just felt more stupid
oh
i don't i don't believe it for a second
i just think you didn't get caught yeah
people
if
i think
if a negative consequence doesn't happen
from a choice a bad choice you've made
you're not going to do it you're not
going to change your thoughts until it
affects you negatively so if that
teacher
never got caught nothing bad ever came
they're still going to do it even though
it is
bad
and i i think the older you get the more
you see people's life choices that catch
up to them the consequences come up
but like there's a lot of [ __ ] that i
did when i was younger because
like that i didn't do because i i knew
the consequence
like my dad caught me smoking weed once
in high school he cried
bruh said not my baby girl yeah that was
a crazy thing
he thought i was a stoner
life was over bruh i i smoked weed once
and i caught like
like they
like the only reason they had the my
friends had a picture of me doing it was
because i didn't like it and so the
picture was the weed and then me going
oh and then that's when my dad sees this
picture he's like my baby's a stoner
like no dad your life is over put you in
rehab now i just wanted to try i heard
the food tasted good
but like i didn't like it anyways it
wasn't my thing but like oh my god i
oh my gosh i i felt so guilty i felt so
bad yeah and like
that it changed like you did something
you had a negative effect think about it
i'm sorry dad
i'm sorry
i didn't mean it
it was just one time thing she's okay
now she's fine living her life out here
yeah
still my brain flipping
right
tom so
but
another thought here
you're describing a world
harlem the urban world
gone yeah
you but you made visits when you were
young you knew the south as well didn't
you did you you you went back to the
south when you were young from time to
time i said back to the south because as
i recall you were born in the south yeah
like
new york went to new york yeah uh well i
think this was courtesy of the marine
corps which happened to locate the boot
camp in south carolina but what about
camp lejeune and north carolina okay so
what i'm getting at is you were of the
generation that saw jim crow with your
own
question no question okay
so well here's
let me read you a quotation this is from
an article that got a lot of attention
in the atlantic a couple of years ago
called the case for reparations
by tan nahisi coates
quote
white supremacy is a force so
fundamental to america smash or pass
smashing pass
he's a black man i'm kitty pass i think
he's kind of cute he's attractive he's
attractive smash
where you at
sorry i know this is a serious video i
think light of the mig light of the
moment
but it is difficult to imagine the
country without it
reparations is the price we must pay to
see ourselves squarely close quote
and tom sowell who actually saw jim crow
with his own eyes and experienced it
responds how
it would be nice to know his uh
evidence for what he said just to be
old-fashioned about it
uh
no it was a rotten system
but i don't know how how we get from
that to reparations i mean
what we see in the united states in
terms of the bad things you see all
around the world
if you were to give reparations to
everyone whose ancestors had been slaves
i suspect that you would have to give
reparations to more than half the entire
population of the globe
slavery was not confined to one set of
races i suspect that most of the people
who either slaves or slave owners around
the world were neither white nor black
i mean this was this was a universal
curse of the human species africa
the middle east asia
and and it continued elsewhere
so
i can understand that because if you
give
if you give reparations to
black people
what about overseas the jews
you have to be reparations to them the
holocaust you give reparations to them
it's like then
those are the ones i'm off the top of my
head but there's other areas it's like
and i ireland had it too actually it was
uh i don't know if it was i think they
called it
indentured servants but if you look at
like the life expectancy was lower than
slaves wow it was
yeah like it happened everywhere
and like
for
for a black person to say like okay
i guess i understand that
reparations would be needed for
everybody so like
for
i'm trying to like say it right
it's like
you
it's hard to say like
well everybody should get reparations
like well
this happened that happened and this is
different it was like it's the same
situation because my mom would say that
to me she would always bring up the
holocaust i'm like but
it's different
but it's not
if
if
the world
gave reparations to every single race
that was
done wrong then there it would be more
than just black people and that's
if you're not open to understanding that
it's like you're just going to be like
no like
we need it we need it we need it but
it's like we
don't we don't necessarily need it
because if you depend on it you're going
to be
sitting and waiting for that to come
your whole life and stay in the same
situation that you're in your whole life
waiting for someone to
give you reparations
for something that happened
many many years ago when it's like if
you want better for your life
i've literally thought of kim kardashian
if you want better get up and go to work
if you want better like you can
choose better but it's not
it's just not
like taught to us that you can choose
better i don't say it's not taught to us
but it's more so that it's
less taught to us like you can you can
choose to do better with your life you
don't have to
follow in the footsteps of everybody
that came before yes they may have done
this done that but you don't have to
choose that life to have a better life
and
yeah
and you know what's oh my gosh you know
it's crazy that
i i hate talking about this because it
just like
claps no but like you realize not all
slaves and slave owners had like a bad
relationship it was wrong absolutely but
like there were accounts of like slaves
slave owners or slaves being very loyal
to their slave owners even after slavery
ended like there's accounts of like a
kid that was like the slave owner's son
and um
the son um
like was a drunk and all the slaves like
took care of him even after slavery was
abolished
because it wasn't as simple as like like
if you're born into a family that has
slaves right they can't just let them go
free because then like they'll be all in
poverty like how would they exist in
society like there's writings of people
saying i think this is a terrible
institution but i don't know what to do
and you know what i'm saying yeah and i
don't i'm not like i'm not trying to
take that away like it was wrong like
absolutely but like it wasn't
there were there were accounts on both
sides it wasn't like every slave owner
was like a terrible person and the
problem is when you look at history you
have to look at it as the side of the
oppressor
that's what they always say if you
really want to understand history
it's interesting you say that there's a
video i saw
and um
it was the this i forgot who was
interviewing but it was a group of white
people sitting down and they were like
i don't i don't know what why people
think that
like
slaves are in chains and this that the
third and they were treated badly
because
my
grandparents or like
my parents had slaves but they were
treated like they were regular people
and i'm like how can you say that when
da da like you don't know it's like i
don't know either i don't know
where i'm only i only know what was
taught to me and what was taught to me
was
the
bad side of it and now it's like was
there
was there certain situations where
um
where
slaves were
treated
correctly or treated as equal and it's
like if i say that which i just did it's
like how can you say that you're you're
black you you don't support it's like i
i like you just i know it's bad like yes
they're worse situation but i'm like
thinking like
were there other were there better
situations because like how can you
be
beaten
treated like the scum of the earth and
when you're free
you go back it's like
it doesn't make sense well because some
people went back to work for them
because it's like okay like the only
reason i know this is because i read
this uh us like a kid that was like born
in slavery guys people in the comments
probably will know who he was like i
think he died around the 20s or 30s
maybe but like whenever he was alive he
was like born as a slave and he he just
gave his like life's experience and part
of it was he was talking about how like
the slaves were very loyal to that owner
because like they all really liked him
and like took care of the sun
and like um
i don't it just wasn't
and like even after slavery was over
they all stayed because they were just
loyal to him because if you're born as a
guy like who inherits a plantation if if
you let everybody just go they're going
to be in poverty how would they exist in
society yeah that's what that's what and
the only reason i know that is because i
read the this guy's diary where he
talked about that and the slave owner is
talking about like i think this is a
horrible institution
but
if i let everybody go they're gonna
they're gonna be in a worse situation
yeah
but you don't think about that
and because even me saying this makes me
nervous because i'm not i'm not sweating
right now and i'm like jesus no because
i'm not i'm not trying to say it was
good in any way it was a terrible
institution but yeah
it was and
what they're talking about right now
welfare
i in my eyes from what they're saying
it's a terrible institution because it's
changed the trajectory of
people
and it's it's like but what
what can you do you can't pull out the
rug off from underneath someone right
now that is depending on it until
there's like steps to it's like when a
child is nursing you got to take steps
to
the win uh whatsoever to
take them away from what they've known
for so long to start feeding them with
the body you just can't be like oh i'm
gonna pop you off and put a bottle in
your mouth like you don't need this
anymore but it's like
they're gonna go into shock and not know
what to do and
i don't know i think when people face
consequences quicker they come up with
solutions quicker
so for example did you know anyone
during covid that didn't work because
the government was giving them money
yes i knew so many people
but the second they stopped with the
payments a lot of them got a job real
quick that is true that is true they
figured it out
and i just think like when it starts to
affect your life you just start thinking
of solutions no i don't i don't know the
answer i'm not i'm not a policymaker
or maybe let me know in the comments
long after
uh it was abolished in the western
countries
let me try this uh
sticking with tanahisi codes
it's shelby talk shelby steel talks
about white guilt
and in tana he see coach you get this is
the thing i used to feel so guilty for
being white oh my god this is this is a
thing this is such a thing when i was
younger
especially when i was like in high
school because i was just pushed so much
that like white people are bad white
people this
that was like i don't know d have you
heard of that or no white guilt yeah
i've yeah i've heard of it
but i'm
i've never talked to it
i've never talked about it to a white
person to be like what do you think
about white girls yeah because when
they're like talking about all the stuff
that white people did like in schools
and stuff that was bad i'm like
but then i was like i'm not even from
the u.s i'm from my parents my parents
are from lithuania
i'm not even technically i wasn't even
there
yeah i don't know who did that but
not the lithuanians what's in me
almost the counterpart of that
a kind of
african-american claim against the white
guild
and this seems it
beginning with the abolitionists even
beginning before the civil war
you see almost every generation there's
some expression
racism and slavery shall because of this
correctly of course the sin of slavery
is so deeply and it's something we still
live with how do we expiate it how do we
get past it is there something we can do
to relieve ourselves of this legacy oh i
think you should repeat it
if you were a slave owner i i don't see
a reason why you should feel differently
on the other hand
i can't get over the idea of a
apologizing for what b did
okay uh even when they're contemporaries
much less when you're when they when one
is dead and the other's alive
all right i mean scalia i remember
saying you know that uh i i i owe no man
anything
because uh people who look like me did
something that people look like him
okay so just get past it
get to work yeah all right tom sowell's
view is get an education stay married
and do your job
roughly yeah all right charles murray
i'm taking you used to write a column
every so often called random thoughts on
the
scene and so i'm giving you a little
little snippets here of the passing
scene as in our final questions charles
murray in his 1984 book losing ground
and charles murray writes about
discussions in academia and government
about the effort to close the gap again
between african americans and whites
quote
1984 quote whites had created the
problem it was up to whites to fix it
and there was very little in the
dialogue that treated blacks as
responsible actors close quote has that
changed no it is not
all right
on on we go to the passing scene your
friend your longtime friend walter
williams
now we come to current politics the
bottom line is that president donald
trump does not have the personal
character that we would want our
children to imitate but
save his misguided international trade
policies has turned out to be a good
president
tom
i think his policies have been by and
large have been uh policies that were
far better than that of previous
democratic or republican administrations
so
i go by the consequences okay i mean he
he hasn't produced the right rhetoric
but the fact is that uh
unemployment among low-income people
black hispanic included uh
is a level that is far lower than it's
been in decades
i will say this
about
donald trump
he
he ran the country not as a politician
as a
from a business standpoint and that's
something that he's good at
and
i that quote that that man said
about his character traits and what he
has
said the inappropriate things he has
said like yeah i wouldn't i wouldn't
want my child to
look like i want to say that i want to
do that just like donald trump like no
his character traits in that sense like
no
but
the policies and the things he
implemented in the country
during his presidency
can't argue with them he you know
i mean you're just crazy
nobody painted him as a bad guy when he
was in the media
for all those years everyone loved him
when he was in the media like on tv yeah
rappers brought him into like videos he
wasn't sherlock holmes
people loved donald trump until he was
trying to like do something for society
honestly
yeah
and
the media
from
from
my st like from what i saw that
it painted
a lot of things like incorrectly
about what he did during his presidency
and
i wish
and it wouldn't probably never be like
this to where a media can honestly like
say
oh this president did this this
president did that
where do you stand like this is like the
facts
facts they're they're gonna push their
opinions push their thoughts until
jesus comes back i can make one
i could
make one on youtube
we're good
because i
i do think that things would have
been
different if we were shown the facts
like he has done this for this community
has done this for the country he's done
this with the
countries that we are in agreement with
now
why why don't you want him in office and
a lot a lot of the people that didn't
want him in his office because he
they thought he was a certain way and
they didn't want him and it wasn't it
wasn't based off the things that he did
well a lot of times it's one small clip
that goes viral yeah and i'm and i'm i'm
in the bracket where it was like oh i
don't i don't want him after the fact i
was like
it's kind of worse now isn't it
yeah i don't think stuff has happened
i'm like joe
mr biden
miss harris where you at
so yeah
uh
yeah the the the uh
the economy is booming in a way that uh
no one had predicted like
people like uh paul krugman were saying
that when trump gets in the economy is
going to tank no
uh the economy to hit new highs all
right but but but there are so many
people among the intel intelligently
especially who are absolutely immune to
facts it's just as if it's as if they
took their uh anti-fact shots uh every
every every year and the facts will just
not affect it so this brings us back
i can understand i mean i really like my
understanding is limited which is why
i'm going to put this in the form of a
question i can understand the never
trumpers who don't
don't bother me with economic boom
because this man is on my television
screen every single night and i can't
stand him i can understand i can see
that impulse i can i kind of miss him
like honestly they'll say what they want
he was entertaining he was so
entertaining it was interesting he was
funny you can't
he was he was wrong okay a lot of time
he was an [ __ ] but like you remember
when he did that whether like you've
called women pigs and he's like except
like
i don't remember that he he said okay
they said to him
like it was um some fox news reporter
where she's like
okay like donald trump you have said
this about women like you've called
women pigs you've called this this and
this and he said i never said that
except rosie o'donnell
oh he's a very interesting person and
yeah we just we just don't we won't dive
into that
i understand what this is the second
consecutive president united states that
i automatically turn off when i'm
watching on television
all right keep the remote right next to
oh yeah okay who was the first obama got
it
uh you're totally bipartisan in that
regard
no other way
but the great society the larger point
that you've been making here the great
society the war on poverty
this is now six
decades of experience yes and we have as
you have said the gap hasn't closed
we've got
dissolution of the family structure
rising crime rates that i don't
understand
how can it be
that
the people
now i don't know how to remain
bipartisan but democrats liberals the
progressives
just are not
the evidence is in this has not worked
like after half more than half a century
there's still a refusal to look at the
evidence
yes and then and has even a tendency to
falsify the evidence
and how come
i think people become uh
attached to a vision
and uh that really warps the way they
see the
human beings have an enormous capacity
to rationalize yeah all right again
notes on the passing scene an article
from the new york times just a couple of
days ago quote now this is the longest
quotation but it's important to lay out
the facts here over the last decade the
charter school movement gained
significant foothold in new york the
movement hoped to set a national example
if charter schools could make it in a
deep blue state like new york they could
make it anywhere
over a hundred thousand students in the
in in the city's charter schools are
doing well on state tests and tens of
thousands are on waiting lists but the
election the election of this november
suggested that the golden era of charter
schools is over
the insurgent democrats democrats did
well across new york but especially in
the state senate have repeatedly
expressed hostility to the movement
close quote and tom sowell responds to
that set of facts how
oh it that that really is one of the
moral outrages
that for many kids
who cut from a very poor background
and who parents may not have had much
education a decent education is the one
thing they have to have
to have a better life
and these schools have been absolutely
uh spectacular
uh the charter schools charter schools
the successful ones now there are a few
that weren't
but
for example a few years ago
on a statewide new york statewide math
tests
there was an elementary school grade 4 i
believe
in harlem
which whose students passed those tests
at a higher rate than any fourth grade
kids anywhere in the state of new york
i mean we're talking scarsdale ridecliff
places like that
the success academy schools as a whole
their students
pass
both the math and the english statewide
tests
at a higher rate than any school system
school district
in the entire state of new york uh
the vast majority of the kids in the
success academy schools are either black
or hispanic
if you look at the five
highest scoring
district school districts in the state
in terms of the percentage of the
students who passed the math or the
english test
uh
their average family income
ranges from
four four times that
of the kids in the success academy
schools to more than nine times
the family income of the kids and the
academies success academy schools
and yet the mayor of new york is doing
his darndest
to to to put a stop to the expansion
of
of schools in general but
his special ira is aimed at the success
academy schools and this is happening
all over the country because they make
the you the teachers unions look bad
that run the public schools
what what's the political motivation why
would mayor de blasio have an out for
the charter schools such as success
academy well the teachers union are on a
major reason
uh and the we're talking about the the
money they contribute the number of
votes they contribute
uh
and
the schools and what and what's
happening again not just in new york but
other parts of the country including
california
is that they they they have all there's
all kind of chicanery uh to prevent the
charter schools from expanding that's
why you have tens of thousands on the
waiting list it's not that the charter
school is not willing to expand but
every conceivable obstacle is put in
their way
because
because everything is connected
they need the votes from the teachers
and the yeah
pearl and you know what's crazy out of
them on monday you did this to me
at the beginning of the week on monday
you know what's crazy out of the 13 000
per kid
that um this city of chicago gets 50 of
that goes towards like pensions and
teachers wow so it's like not even going
towards it's going towards um i'm pretty
sure 50 is towards pensions so that
means half of the money that each kid
like the school gets for the kid is
going towards teachers that don't even
teach anymore because it's their like um
their their pension
because they weren't expecting people to
live this long because they were
thinking oh let's retire teachers it's
like that's a good thing
but now the students now get less money
and less funding
and we have to pay
i'm gonna need something after this
goodness the one if you let that go at
the natural pace it would be very hard
for the public schools to compete
and one of the things they're doing is
imposing the same kinds of restrictions
on the on on the charter schools that
that made this public school so bad for
example restrictions on being able to
get rid of kids who are running a muck
in this and ruining the education of
everybody else
and the charter schools don't tolerate
that
uh the things that are tolerated in the
public schools are unbelievable
so when i asked you a moment ago how do
we bring back the
the standards of the harlem in which you
grew up the answer is that's a hard
thing to do but we do know how to do one
thing we do know how to establish
schools where the kids in present-day
harlem have a shot they have a chance of
getting a good idea you don't have to
bring back the past uh even if you could
uh because we have it in the present we
have to we have this happening and so we
know how to do that and the democratic
establishment in new york wants to shut
it down yes
and the republican establishment stands
mute stands mute
you know i love talking to you but i
really don't know why it's all it's all
discouraging tom you mentioned again a
moment ago the um
the way young americans
uh
flocked to bernie sanders gallup poll
this summer the proportion of americans
aged 18 to 29 that holds a favorable
view of capitalism 45
the proportion that holds a favorable
view of socialism 51
now i would like you to take a look at a
brief video of alexandria
ocasio-cortez who at the age of 29
calling herself a democratic socialist
has just been elected to the house of
representatives from new york and
although she's not seated yet in the new
congress she went to washington and one
of her first acts was to participate in
a sit-in
in the offices
of house majority leader nancy pelosi
that is to say her the leader of her own
party yes so here's a brief
video i just want to let you all know
how proud i am of each and every single
one of you for putting yourselves and
your bodies and
everything on the line to make sure that
you save our planet our generation and
our future
it's so incredibly important
we have to get to 100 renewable energy
in ten years there is no other option
tom
to her supporters to the supporters of
bernie sanders to young americans what
would you say
i would say
get some facts first know what you're
talking about before you start spouting
out this kind of stuff
asked one of the things i do in a new
new book as i suggest that uh
there's a certain
opinion about what happened in the 1920s
where the taxes were cut from the
highest tax rate was cut down from 73 to
24
and the argument was this is tax cuts
for the rich
and i have suggested that the students
and that uh secretary of the treasury
did this in in support of us trickle
down theory and so forth and i suggest
that the student will do a wonderful
project to go read what the secretary of
the treasury actually said andrew mellon
in the 1920s yeah these tax cuts and
then
go on the internet and get the uh
internal revenue official
data on who paid how much taxes in the
1920s
and it turns out if you do that you find
that andrew mellon said the exact
opposite of what he has attributed is
attributed to him in textbooks that have
been
sold widely for decades on end through
successive uh uh
conditions
and what you'll find is that in the
when the tax rate was at 73 percent
uh the people who are making over uh a
hundred thousand dollars a year and
that's maybe a couple of million in
today's money
uh paid 30 of the taxes
and after the so-called tax cuts for the
rich
they paid 65 of all the taxes
and the people with incomes under five
thousand dollars which is also was a
nice income in those days
uh who were paying uh 15 when the tax
rate was what was uh cut but before the
tax check was cut and after it was cut
they paid uh just under a quarter of one
percent of all the taxes and so we hear
how and so there's all kinds of
indignation in these scholarly books
we're not talking about just political
propaganda uh uh how this this was a
bonanza for the rich and so on
and uh people with ordinary incomes paid
practically nothing in income tax after
the tax cuts and though and millionaires
uh the share of millionaires was uh i
think four percent before that
and and it was 19 afterwards
uh and but but the fact that 19 of the
population was millionaires
i understand that right i thought he was
saying
maybe maybe he was oh was he saying four
percent was the tax rate i think that
was four percent the tax rate that's
what i thought i was like or nineteen
like 19 percent yeah was that okay never
mind i i
simply do not matter
they they say these words they say isn't
that crazy though that it was published
incorrectly in books
yeah like what
it's like what information are you like
what information are you giving us to
where you're
why are you publishing this incorrectly
do you not know it yourself or you just
don't want to publish the correct
information i want to get elected in the
future
they trickle down and it's like saying
abracadabra and all the miraculous
things follow from that
tom sol author of a forthcoming edition
of discrimination and disparities would
you close
by reading a brief quotation from your
1987 book one of my favorites a conflict
of visions
logic of course is not the only test of
a theory
empirical evidence is crucial
and yet social visions have shown a
remarkable ability to evade suppress or
explain away discordant evidence
historic evasions of evidence are a
warning not a model
dedication to a cause may legitimately
entail sacrifices of personal interest
but not sacrifices of mind or conscience
dr thomas sol thank you thank you
okay
what are you what'd you think hi hi how
you holding up
how are you doing
it's
like this is a video that i want to show
my family be like what are your thoughts
like you gotta record it when you go
home yeah
i will because i
i have
parents who
essentially were alive or alive before
these laws were implemented and alive
after these laws were implemented and
it's like how did they how did they
affect you and how
how did they affect what what was life
like before they were implemented and
what was life like after
and
it's
you can't understand no
it's like if you you don't know what you
don't know
and you're just walking around life like
you may know like what you're taught
like the overarching thing like all i
knew about welfare was the simple stuff
but not like the depths
of it and how
it just has
affected so much
okay do you think about like you it kind
of makes sense the way the media runs
like you understand that they try to get
people emotional so they don't think
like this yeah and so that's when they
like in the last video when he was
talking about like tribalism
versus um
i forgot what the was you know what word
i'm talking about yes whatever i don't
know what the other one was but but it
was because like it was basically saying
like like in the in the case of me it'd
be like a woman like like that's the
excuse instead of personal
responsibility get married do this do
this do this it's like blaming it on the
fact that you're a woman but it's
because they want to get you to vote for
them because they're going to give you
handouts
and those handouts will make you vote
for them
because you want to keep getting them
yeah i'm pretty sure if there was
if there was someone that was going into
office and they're like you know what
we're taking steps to
end
welfare and like people don't understand
what the negative effects it has on
someone they're going to be like no i'm
not voting for them because i i need it
and what do they do they'll paint them
as this mean they'll say and and they're
taking away from the the less fortunate
they're taking away from them they're
not going to give them opportunity they
would paint it as it's negative but it's
like
no that'd be something that'd be
helpful
in the long run and then they go after
your because what they do is like like
whenever okay whenever i bring up these
points what do they do with me they
remind me that i'm a privileged white
woman and nothing that i say can be
correct yeah and that's what they do
that's what they do with these
politicians like donald trump when he
was bringing these policies up they'll
say oh he was a rich kid he failed all
these businesses he's like he couldn't
possibly understand you and it doesn't
matter if the person that's passing the
policy understands you like and you can
tell when someone's like doing something
that's correct like a lot of times
they'll go for their character yep and
like and when it shouldn't like to be
honest i don't really care about the
person i vote for as character i care
about what policies do they pass and
what are they doing mm-hmm it's like
when i hire someone for a job it doesn't
matter like i don't care what they do in
their free time
true like that's really true that's
their life
i care about what you do like you on my
channel what you do at your dorm
like obviously i want good people but
like but like it's not my business but
you can when you come here like if you
watch the video like that's what matters
and that's what i look at like politics
as yeah
and if they make you laugh it's little
perks and make you chuckle
man
pearl you didn't wreck me on this monday
i'm sorry ah
ideas meal oh my goodness
okay guys let us know in the comments a
most liked comment will react to next i
don't know because you said that last
time we had this one
bruh i know i was like oh for real
i was like you guys gonna do me like
this video please next one make it make
it lighter i'm kidding
um guys and go subscribe to her channel
too new videos are coming soon reaction
videos vlogs behind the scenes they are
coming soon so go subscribe i'm gonna
get her set up you guys all
they're coming i'm telling you they're
coming i promise pinky promise
yeah go subscribe you gonna do the outro
yeah so if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you
like
and subscribe and then comment down
below what you like what you dislike and
some videos for us to react to
okay guys bye
[Music]